Yvonne is glad to see you once again in
Croatia you're playing for the third
time already and this event attracts
lots of crowd here I mean many people
come for the to the plane hole to watch
you especially playing uh does it give
you extra motivation uh yes but also
gives extra pressure as well so as I
said for me this is one of the most
important tournaments in a year because
I played with the strongest players in
the world
and I'm trying to do my best and
you know make make myself
[Music]
shown in the best possible way uh
considering the chess part and
also it's the strongest tournament in
Croatia and that's why Always attracts a
lot of people to watch and also the the
best players in the world are here so I
guess all of this matters yeah do you
think chess is getting more and more
popular in Croatia how do you feel yeah
I think in general in the world it's and
it's same in Croatia in last couple of
years
mostly thanks to this online boom I
think just is becoming way more popular
than it used to be
and I like where this trend is going so
far yeah yeah that definitely goes this
way and I remember you playing last year
in this event you had so many winning
great positions and I remembered you
spoiled many of them but still you
showed your strengths and that you're
able of course to fight with all chess
players here my question is did you try
to change something in your prep in your
approach to this event and I know that
you had this camp together with one
forest and also some other regions how
did it go uh well this Camp wasn't so
intended for me but I always like
to go there and enjoy just playing some
some church before this event
about my losses from the previous year
yeah it was tough messing up so many
winning positions or losing the Drone
positions uh this this year I'll try to
be a bit more focused
in the time travel uh since I think
that's my weakest part of the game when
I'm like down
[Music]
let's say one minute unless I start to
play very very badly and
I'm hoping that this year I will improve
that that aspect of the game yeah for
sure I mean good luck with that and my
last question is you know in 2021 2022
there were there was a different field
this time we have many new players and
whom I looking forward to play against
uh the most
uh well usually I like to play against
Magnus since that's always
[Music]
uh how to say
I forgot the word the right word in
English
yeah challenging exactly you know what I
mean and uh
besides I think I I've already played
with everyone else in a field many times
so I know the players as well
and uh actually last year it seemed like
very strong yeah so this year
is similar but
it's a lot depends on my on my form and
whether I will be
I'll be able to to convert good
positions yeah if I reach the yeah
that's great all the best of luck for
you in the tournament thank you very
much
[Music]